hello everyone today I'm gonna get right
to it I'm gonna continue with what we
were doing last couple lectures and that
is I'm gonna be analyzing the debate I
had with Peter a mathematical physicist
who challenged the rope model light
gravity etc and what are the problems I
have with it well I been talking a
little bit about that in the last couple
lectures here's the summary or the
points that I'm gonna make how much it
concentrate on a couple of them here the
first one will be that number two there
didn't understand the golden principle
of physics number four this miss
strategic words as petty semantics he
didn't read up on the rope model but I'm
not gonna discuss that specifically
today he used the debunk planetary model
of the atom and he in order to do so he
improvised a bogus fabric medium that he
says keeps the electron bound to the to
the broke down to the nucleus okay so
those four items are the one I'm going
to be talking about specifically I'm
talking about objects and I think this
is fundamental to physics real physics
genuine physics you need to have an
object so that's where we start I start
with the golden principle and this is
what I said to Peter at the time we
discussed this I said physics requires I
told them there's the golden principle
physics it's a non-negotiable principle
every physicist must accept this one at
the point of a gun
there's no challenging this there's no
questioning this physics requires an
object you can't do physics without an
object and Peter answers with a very
ambiguous answer he says probably you're
right probably it's like he never
learned this basic lesson this is not
probably issue this is a yes or no type
of issue and the answer is yes you do
need an object as he said later on but
even though he said that he never used
an object and in all of mathematical
physics you will not find objects when
we're talking about invisible entities
they are all done with concepts and
Peter who is essentially just another
mathematical physicists out there it
doesn't matter which one you talk to
Peter's just as good as any they all do
it without objects and this is the big
problem of mathematical physics they do
physics with concepts they move concepts
around and I'm saying that all words in
the dictionary can be divided into two
categories there either objects or
concepts and objects that which has
shape and concept is that which doesn't
but essentially a concept is a relation
it's a word that invokes our bodies two
objects a concept is a relation between
two objects therefore object is to one
what a concept is to two you need to
define the word object before you define
the word concept that's the foundation
that's where we start that's our
starting point okay so what was the
problem well he never used an object and
he tried to convince me or he's got this
notion just like any other mathematical
physics I'm not really gonna pick on
Peter in this case because he's just
standard you know same as anybody else
in mathematical physics he you
represents establishment essentially
that's what he's been told in college
this is what he studied this is what he
took tests on this is what he got this
degree on okay and so the first problem
that we've got is that you know he says
I said you know what is an object and
and he answers if I can get up here I
said what is an object and he says your
point is that it has to have size no
that was not my point but this is what
he understood and as a result he got it
all wrong anything that came afterward
was simply you know unfounded he said we
don't know what the size of some
particles is it's not a question of no
what the size of a particle is got
nothing to do with it the question is
whether it has shape not if whether it
has size size is a an issue that you
have to compare against another object
and therefore that's why the size is not
the criterion to use for defining the
word object for the purposes of physics
he says particle is a linguistic
shorthand again you know they're they're
they're using words that they're not
supposed to particle is not supposed to
be a shorthand either it's a particle or
it ain't one of the two you can't say
well you know I just said particle but I
didn't really mean particle you know I
really meant something else no the
particle is a corpuscle you don't mean
corpuscle don't use the word particle
because all you're trying to do is
mislead the public into thinking that
particle is what it really isn't and
actually you know like I said last week
the word particle means vibration of a
field that's what it means
it's an excitation of a field and a
field is not a physical object the field
is a bunch of numbers so essentially
they ended up you know with the motion
of numbers that fall around a region so
we have all these numbers in a region
fact I think I've got it here somewhere
let's see if I can find it here it is I
wasn't planning on using this today but
here that's a that's a particle
according to quantum mechanics vibration
of a field what is a field a bunch of
numbers in a region so there you have a
whole bunch of numbers in a region
specifically they go from higher numbers
in the center to lower numbers on the
outskirts and this extends all the way
to infinity as they always say and so
they have a vibrational field is entity
I guess because this is just a flat
two-dimensional
image or cross section of what particle
is supposed to be a field extends in
every direction radially and so the
issue here is that this is what they're
saying the particle is this is not a
particle this is certainly not a
corpuscle and this is not what we call
something or an object or a thing for
the purposes of physics but this is what
they say we're gonna be doing quantum
mechanics with okay so so he got that
one wrong he says you know it's a
particles of linguistics shorthand
saying that it has shape that's a little
bit uncertain something doesn't have
shape does a dog have shape does a tree
have shape does the rocket ship
hopefully everything I say if it's a
thing and that's essentially the
definition an object is that which has
shape and so he says that's a bit
uncertain because he's referring
especially to the electron use answer
particle and we don't know sizes because
we're still trying to measure it and
whether it's a thing it shares the only
property with all other objects in the
universe in that shape so it better
doesn't know if it's got shaped and I'm
not sure what these people are talking
about Oh sound has started rapping again
let's see uh shut down and take it back
up okay here goes
you
am i okay now Tom can you hear me okay
let me know as soon as you hear me
whether you can hear me okay okay
good I'm not sure why sometimes I get I
get one of two problems I get sound
which starts vibrating or I get the
image which goes very blurry and all I
can do right now is just unplug it and
plug it back in and continue rolling so
please let me know if the sound or the
image go out of whack anyways I was
saying that he says that he doesn't know
whether the electron has shape and they
still don't they're still not sure about
the electron size and again we don't
care about size but for sure it had
better have shape otherwise we don't
really know what they're talking about
that means they're not talking about
objects anymore okay anyways he says we
have precision tests to determine what
it what is the shape of the electron we
don't need any precision this is a
conceptual issue we don't need to
measure anything here we don't know yet
we don't know the electron size okay we
don't we don't need to know the size
again you know and other particles are
produced when we probe it so he says
well you know they all get these
confusions because they try to measure
it they get something else they get
interference they get some noise and so
they can't tell the size or the shape
this is a conceptual issue all objects
must have shaped by definition if they
don't have shape they don't belong to
physics period because that's what the
golden principle tells us okay so that's
that's what he failed to understand and
so we go to the next step and and say
here's what an object ain't and I'm just
gonna summarize this here and well this
is what it's not
you cannot it's it's not that which you
can see
that which you can touch not that which
has size radius diameter not that which
can move not that we can measure has
mass volume not that that which we can
talk about not that which is a noun or a
subject of a sentence or not that which
is made up blah blah blah blah blah
whatever whatever it's made out of an
object is that which has shaped that's
the definition we're gonna use for
physics anyone who doesn't like it had
better be able to defend his counter
proposed period that's it and so again
the fact that the mathematicians in the
last ten thousand years have never
defined the word object one and more
important than that never you found how
important it is to define it because
it's the bread and butter of physics it
shows you that they're completely you
know not dealing with physics at all
they're out in the field who knows what
they're doing you know but they think
they're doing physics they call it
physics and all they're doing
essentially is a bunch of numbers and
equations and stuff that has nothing to
do with physics okay so that's the main
problem we then got into a discussion
first on spacetime because obviously the
one of the questions are rational
physicists s is you know what is this
thing called space-time that you're
gonna do gravity with remember gravity
is the warping of space that's
essentially what Einstein proposed and
if gravity is the warping of space-time
for space depending on which
mathematician you talk to then as a
minimum I want to see what their warping
and before you can warp something you
better have a thing in there and what is
it gonna be it's got to have shape you
can't say well I don't know if it's have
seen I've never measured it no you can't
say that not in physics this is a
conceptual issue you don't measure
anything you just say by definition
objects that would test shape you're
saying that space-time is an object
please draw it that's what you say
that's that's the discussion if he can't
draw it he doesn't have a theory he's
got some religion
you know that he's trying to push down
your throat but he certainly doesn't
have a theory okay so what's the issue
the issues we got into this discussion
this back and forth this dialogue and he
goes something like this
let's see if I put it well this is the
summary of it it says Peter insinuates a
concept called 4d space-time as a fabric
you use that word fabric and you hear it
lots of times in general relativity he
was the first one that I heard that
introduced it into quantum mechanics but
he it's it's very well-known that
space-time is known as a fabric the
fabric of space-time and I'm saying you
know there's only 3d from here to
eternity
or gods heaven there's no 2 d1 d0 to
York 4d and Peter answers to that I
would disagree oh my god that's that's
when we started having a problem he
disagreed on the one hand he says we
need an object to do physics but now he
doesn't realize that he's contradicting
it with that statement that he disagrees
that there's gotta that there's only 3d
from here to God's heaven you know you
can say that Q that a square is an
object it is an object's just an
inexistent object but that's not out
there that's not in in the real world I
can also imagine a table and the one
that I'm imagining is not out there in
the real world it's it's just in my head
so you know things that you imagine
things that you can imagine and
geometric figures ideal geometric
figures those are not real those that
are not out there what exists out there
are all 3d there's no exception
there's nothing less than 3d there's
nothing greater than 3d these people
trying to introduce something called
space-time which is 44 dimensional and
they say you know this four-dimensional
thing is we live inside it you know the
earth the solar system everything is
within this box this bag whatever they
match it out there that is
four-dimensional unimaginable I say okay
and here's the discussion here was the
dialogue that we had I'm gonna go over
it because it's important to find out
you know what his argument
is okay so this bill I bill I'm bill
Missouri I'm the guy that's asking down
and said I need to know what gravity is
what physical object is mediating
gravity I need to have the eyes of God
to see what invisible mediator that
invisible meteor in order to have an
explanation an explanation for gravity
that's what we don't have today we have
a lot of math and no explanations Peter
says the conservative nature of some
physicist it is in the language in which
they describe these phenomena so so
there he's talking about describing
first of all Cain he says it's in the
language okay so they talk about fabric
of space-time that dense so this you can
take to be a physical object so when you
say something bends yeah you can say
that whatever bends has to be a physical
object the question is whether the state
the phrase fabric of space-time
qualifies as an object that's the issue
and I'm saying uh-uh but that but it's
not you know though it's not a physical
object you said what do you say that
because it's a concept it's is time and
object or a concept and he answers is a
fabric an object or a concept and I'm
saying a fabric of what he says a fabric
of space-time so we're back to square
one
and I'm saying it's type of time as a
concept so we're making a fabric out of
a concept and then he changes a little
bit his story he said how about a fabric
in space-time no longer is space-time
the fabric no longer space-time is the
thing now is some kind of container and
the fabric is within space-time so again
we're talking about some kind of ether
that's essentially the wedding is
raising there and so we got to go back
to square one and say well you know are
we saying that space is a physical logic
it's time a physical object
these are euphemisms these are figures
of speech okay like the word particle
etcetera okay and I'm saying that anyone
who works with these things or is not a
physicist but Arnab stresses so you
answer you said let's take it to the
next level of coming up with he says for
example I can describe some a better
description of space-time at least we
call it space-time as
fabric again he insists that space-time
is some kind of fabric and so he goes
back and forth whether the fabric is
within space-time like a space-time is a
separate object or container or whatever
and other times he said well space-time
itself is the fabric so they go back and
forth it's like but we don't care we got
all these ideas and we can use any of
any one of them no no he's got a specify
for the purposes of physics whether
space-time is the fabric course fabric
is something within space-time either
way we got a problem because space-time
is not a physical object so he can't use
it as a container so he can't use it as
a fabric he can't use it as a container
and I'm saying you keep saying that
space-time is a fabric obviously it's
not and again he either doesn't realize
what he's saying or he doesn't agree
with it or he's got problems with that
and that's where the problem that's
where he violates the golden principle
which says you must have a physical
object of new physics he's trying to do
physics with a concept called time and
he's treating it as a physical object
saying it's some kind of fabric you know
God's fabric angels fabric spiritual
fabric I don't know and as to how he
continues and I want to go through this
first before I analyze it says it
depends on what you mean by space and
time we would need to define that yeah
of course but at least you can say that
we can have a fabric that has something
associated with space and human time it
seems to change with time and I'm saying
that's why we got to start at the
beginning state that physics requires an
object and we need to define what an
object is for the purposes of physics
space-time does not qualify as an object
first because it is unimaginable it's
four-dimensional and then they say don't
try to imagine and then because you
can't draw it you can't make a picture
of it so what are we talking about and
and now we get on a tangent he says who
told you that we can't imagine it and so
now we really get into a little debate
here because it means he hasn't done a
minimum of research on this word he has
no idea what he's talking about it's
it's well known but you know all
mathematical physicists that you cannot
imagine space-time all you can do is
explain it
in steps or by analogy with
two-dimensional you know the
2-dimensional flatland or he cannot
imagine three dimensions and likewise we
cannot imagine four dimensions other
people say no you can you really can all
you gotta do is see a box through time
and the box is 3d you see it through
time there's your 4d and some one day
they go through all these analogies but
you I can't make a picture a photograph
of the space-time I cannot take a
picture of a four-dimensional anything
because it would have to have a fourth
perpendicular line to all the other
three we cannot even imagine that and so
they say no you can't you got to be in
the fourth dimension to see that okay
all we can do it is by analogy it turns
out that Peter wasn't aware of all this
so he says who told you you that we
can't imagine it and so I read out to
him what what guru of physics
mathematical physics Stephen Hawking
says in his book he says a
four-dimensional space called space-time
it's impossible to imagine a
four-dimensional space I mean that's as
clear as it is and he kind of dismisses
that like saying well that's Stephen
Hawking well he's not the only one
there's a lot of these guys that tell
you that and you know so he he says that
I'm you know like you know I'm really
going out of my way pigeonholing the
statement that you're making you're like
if I'm being picky or I'm you know very
semantic about it or whatever he
dismisses this as a valid argument okay
so what is the problem in space-time as
physical object or not I mean do we need
do we need to really go through this to
to say that time is not a physical
object and there's so many people out
there that tell me well it is time a
physical object let me come on a clock
as a physical object time is not is one
second a physical object I mean does it
hit you in the face a time does the word
does the second make you grow older is
that what they're saying and it has some
physical effect on your cells a direct
physical does it push the cell up and
down make you older or whatever so so
when people cannot tell you that whether
time is a physical out
there's a serious problem in there men
in inner mental capacity yeah I mean I I
didn't have to go to even the high
school I learned this in kindergarten
you don't ask whether time is a concept
or not it is a concept and and then you
can define the word concept but for sure
time is not a physical object well he's
got a problem with that because he he
seems to think for some reason and he's
not the only one that you know
space-time is a physical lab do you say
well time is a concept and they said
what is it really you know but time with
space well that makes a four dimensional
object and again assuming space is a
physical object let's call it a rock
it's three dimensional if we have a rock
plus time does that make Rock time a
physical object and this is what these
people are saying they're saying if I if
I take a three-dimensional object and I
add time to it or multiplied by time or
whatever they do with time the
associated with time I turn it into a
four-dimensional object so these people
really have have a problem a serious
problem these people are not rational at
all you cannot put anything with time
and turn it into a physical object the
addition or multiplication or division
by time does not in any way turn
anything into a four-dimensional object
and that's what essentially these people
are saying anyways so we go through what
what is space-time you know I mean then
let's find out what space-time is at
this point and here you look it up and
here's the Wikipedia so space-time is
any mathematical model it's a
mathematical model where we're talking
about a concept that fuses the three
dimensions of space and the one
dimension of time into a single
four-dimensional continuum they use this
this noun continuum like if they're
speaking you know about a fabric again
and you know this word continuum is very
misleading to continue isn't does not
qualify as an object in physics
hyper-physics another source that I
looked at by the way I looked at Wolfram
and
they don't even have a definition for
space-time they have the word in six of
their articles and no where is the word
space-time defined they just assume you
you understand what it means they do
describe the the metric for what is it
the Minkowski metric and they associate
that with space-time but again they
don't define even the metric what that
is what that is
you know essentially that you don't know
what I mean cause key metric is because
they don't define it it's it's go ahead
and start using it and so there is no
definition in wolfram but here you have
hyper-physics says well attributing a
kind of effective mass to the photon in
one way to the fruit is one way to
describe why the path of light is bent
by a gravity field einstein's approach
in general relativity is to associate a
mass with a curvature of space-time okay
there we have it
DX in other words the existence of a
mass will produce a curvature in
space-time around it so we have a mass
concept right and they're they're
insinuating that there's an elephant you
know but they're talking about his mass
is weight not not the elephant itself so
we're not talking about the object but a
property of the object and this property
will produce a curvature in space-time
so we have a concept producing curvature
and another concept okay that's what
these people are saying from the point
of view that light will follow the
shortest path or follows a geodesic of
space-time then if the Sun curves the
space around it then light passing the
Sun will follow that curvature in other
words they have concepts bending
concepts that's hyper-physics that's the
best explanation they've got for what
spacetime is or the notion of space-time
which is essentially what the wikipedia
says scientific america same thing they
they have an article called what is
space-time great finally we get funny we
get a a good source that tells it what
spacetime is says Albert Einstein
formulated his general theory of
relativity which postulates that gravity
is not a force that propagates through
space like Newton said no but a feature
of space-time itself when you through
hi into dere it arts back to the ground
because Earth distorts the space down
around it so that the paths of the ball
and the ground intersect again this is
totally wrong
this is totally it shows that Scientific
American whoever wrote that article
didn't know what he was talking about
because it turns out that space time in
other words Einstein's field equations
and his the entire context of general
relativity is the macro world is the
cosmic world you cannot apply that to
what these people say the example they
said here throwing a ball high in the
air that's for this you need to use
quantum effects okay you cannot say that
the pen that I let go and falls to the
floor fell there because space is so
curved that the pen falls to the floor
you cannot say that because that's not
what general relativity said general
relativity only applies curves but the
curved space scenario two macro
scenarios cosmic scenarios you cannot
apply general relativity here on earth
okay
and so this example is wrong and again
misleading and again people get the
wrong idea they're just misdirected with
this in physics and more generally in
the Natural Sciences space and time are
the foundations of all theories yeah
foundation of all mathematical theories
not in science for sure yet we never see
space-time directly no kidding
I wonder why rather we infer its
existence from our everyday experience
we assume that the most economical
account of the phenomena we see is some
mechanism that operates within
space-time so we don't have a definition
of space-time even though the article
was titled what is space-time we still
don't know okay and the last one I
checked the Encyclopedia Britannica just
to show you all these more or less say
the same thing spacetime single concept
it's a concept okay not a physical
objects a concept that recognizes the
union of space and time okay
that's what Einstein proposed and
with the mathematicians accept it
gravity is no longer thought of as a
force as in the Newtonian system correct
but as a cause of a warping of
space-time again we're warping time
remember we're warping a concept because
it does say in the first line it's a
concept so they're warping a concept the
word warping can only be used with
objects they're using they're applying
that to a concept
the result is a curved and see there
they're always quoting these words work
being curved okay the result is a curved
space-time in Einstein's curved
space-time a particle follows a word
world blind or geodesic somewhat
analogous to the way billiard ball on a
warp serpent surface would follow a path
determined by the warping or curving of
the surface curving of a surface in a in
a billiard ball that's different than
curbing of a concept okay so the analogy
is not valid yeah I can understand if
you throw a bowling ball on a mattress
on my bed it's gonna push the mattress
downwards right and I can throw a little
ball and it'll try to fall into the hole
we all I don't even need to run the
experiment I can imagine and that's
sufficient for me that is true that's
and they're saying that's what's
happening out there in in the cosmic
world or a scenario or context they're
saying the Sun weighs down space-time
this concept time warps it curves it and
then object like the earth you know if
it weren't for its centrifugal motion
trying to you know radial going around
you know it would fly out of the solar
system if it weren't for the fact that
this curvature pulls it towards the Sun
just a curvature the fact that it's
falling into the hole well aside from
the fact that you know you have
Newtonian hello can you hear me I hope
you can all hear me still please please
someone answer if you can or not
okay but a minute ago I had to interrupt
anyways you know the if the Sun weighs
down the space time obviously you know
the treaty space-time is a physical
object and envy and the only thing that
they have to do is draw it for us and
they do draw it for us here's a drawing
think I have it here yeah here we have
this is hyper physics and they drew
space-time for us thank God I don't see
anything four dimensional in there it's
a flat surface that what they're
indicating here is that it's been bent
downwards so we have a two dimensional
square that's being bent down into a
third dimension by a ball that looks
like the Sun we'll assume it's the Sun
okay no problem and it bends this net
downwards so the question is what I put
there in red what is this light blue
stuff that serves as a background to the
net I mean if the net is space or
space-time what is the blue stuff that
serves as a background to space or
space-time and then obviously you know
we we have the problem that if that
whole square that is two-dimensional not
you know we're not talking about
four-dimensional being bent into three
dimensions we're talking about three
dimensions or two dimensions being bent
into three dimensions we have a square
being turned into a square with a hole
in it and how is this four-dimensional I
don't know yeah you know what they say
well it's an analogy okay an analogy for
what what are we talking about you know
again this space-time is very misleading
because they're talking about the
curvature of space-time and they and
they illustrate it but what are they
Ellis training what is this square you
know this has nothing to do with
four-dimensional first and second we
need to know what that blue background
is that serves as a background to the
net okay so these are the things having
me
especially when I'm trying the punk rope
okay let me read William Reserve's bill
what I did
spend so much time trying to debunk rope
hypothesis with double slit experiment
I'm gonna deal that then the next time
around I'm gonna I'm gonna get to the
slit experiment but today I'd like to
talk more about space-time because it's
got to do with this word fabric that he
used okay I want you to understand that
so so let me just summarize what I'm
trying to do here he used the word
fabric and this is important because
fabric everybody listens to fabric says
you're talking about an object no
problem we don't understand you need
take a piece of cloth and you say it's a
fabric okay we all understand it and so
we associate the word fabric even though
fabric is that it's like the material
it's made out of so fabric is not a
physical object but when someone says
fabric you're thinking of a piece of
cloth and therefore you associate it
with a physical object so he's talking
about the fabric not only of space-time
as I'm dealing with here but he's gonna
be talking about the fabric in quantum
mechanics he's gonna associate it with
what is called a potential and yeah the
rag correct and I'm gonna get that in to
that in a minute but we need to cover
this stuff this this fundamental stuff
because he tries to get away with the
fact that he says we do have an
explanation in mathematical physics we
have an explanation for gravity because
we use a fabric called space-time and we
have an explanation for how the atom
works because we have a fabric that
holds the electron to the nucleus so he
uses this strategic word fabric he
insinuates he's talking about a physical
object he's convinced that he's talking
about a physical object he illustrates
it with a rag right and the question is
is that a physical object and I'm going
to show that it's not here I'm going to
deal with space-time space-time is a
concept you cannot say the fabric of
space-time because there is no fabric of
time time is a concept so to use the
word fabric in relation to time to space
or to space-time is misleading you can
say the
of the skirt that the girls were airing
you can say that but you cannot say the
fabric of love because that's what
they're saying they're saying we have
the fabric of time the fabric of space
the fabric of space-time and yes yeah
says yes the fallacy of reification
that's what it is it's reification and
and and that's you know throughout all
of mathematical physics you will find
this this notion this this
underhandedness where they casually turn
concepts into objects they reaffirmed a
they concret crank concretize them they
turn them into concrete objects okay and
that's what's happening here so but this
guy doesn't realize this and that's
what's troubling because he kind of
improvised he said was the fabric of
space-time you say well is his space and
time a physical object we said well how
about a fabric in space-time so now he's
improvising he's saying you know I don't
know but what if we do this or what do
we do that I mean this guy comes out of
college
he's comes out with a degree he doesn't
know this he's got to know this for sure
he can't be speculating on these it's
like he never paid attention and didn't
care about these things like we don't
care about that all we do is our
equations that's what we care about and
so they're not doing physics again
they're doing their abstracts anyways
hyper-physics once again that space-time
for you there is no fabric there they
turned it into a fabric that blue stuff
with a line through it apparently all
that is the fabric that they're talking
about and again what they've done is
reify a concept that's all they've done
why is this important because that was
the first discussion the first debate
but then he extrapolates this to the
atom okay well we got here he could draw
a picture of his atom what model is he
even using well that's that's what I'm
getting to next he does draw a picture
he does draw a picture of his atom the
question is if the picture qualifies as
a physical object and
so much the electron and nucleus no
problem there the problem is the
material the fabric the whatever that
keeps the electron tied to the nucleus
that's where we have the problem because
that's what mathematical physics cannot
explain in mathematical physics can
point to the earth and it can point to
the Sun okay and you say okay here's the
key question what keeps the earth tied
to the Sun why doesn't the earth fly
away that's when they say the fabric of
space-time so what is this fabric well
we can't tell you we can't show it to
you because it's unimaginable and when
you look at it it's just a bunch of
concepts and it was this concept has
worked and so that's where they go wrong
there now they do the same no he's doing
the same thing to the atom he's saying
you got the nucleus that's the Sun we've
got the tiny electron that's the earth I
mean we're looking at the hydrogen atom
here obviously the most simplest and you
say what keeps the electron tied to the
nucleus what physical object why doesn't
the electron just spontaneously fly away
and what's the answer the answer is
there's a fabric the fabric of what and
that's where he goes into this and so
let's let's see what his argument is
that may make this smaller so I can see
this here this is the discussion this is
the deep the exchange that we have here
okay
and he says he says Peter disappear we
know that there is we know I'm glad you
know they use that word no it's like you
know you can't challenge this because
they know we know that there is an
electron that exists at a single point
in space I can detect a particle in a
location so we can say with a high
degree of accuracy that it is particle
like let me stop there for a second real
quick because we need to comment on this
where does he get this why does he know
that there is a particle in space and
they gate they can detect it as a
particle well when they run the slit
experiment getting back to your question
there or
your comment when they do the slit
experiment they claim to be doing one
particle at a time
Kanna Morra that this and so did Murli
their groups when an Italian the other
one a Japanese group and they claimed
that they did it with electrons that
they had handled and that they handled
one electron at a time so they say they
got this electron shooter you know
they're being shooter and they're
shooting one electron out of the time
they say they handled one electron at a
time and why did they say that because
they were able to locate one cannonball
hid under a screen on whatever the
detector whatever they use I think they
use a detector they were able to detect
one hit at a time so they say ah see it
behaves particle light there's one
electron hitting at the same you know
one right after another you know you
shoot one you sense it you say oh what
electron it's just one electron I sense
there you wait another few seconds maybe
twenty seconds or whatever boom a second
one and no and with that they build
their their lines and again you know
whether that's their conclusion it never
occurred to them that we could be using
a drill bit to make holes you know you
can make holes with a drill bit and
that's a totally different mechanism and
shooting cannonballs at the fort you
know you should cannon balls at the fort
yeah you get a hit on the fort wall and
you know you can measure that you can
detect it in whatever how about if we
put a drill against that seam or can you
make a hole there yeah you can also do
that and so the question is is the
Cannonball interpretation the only one
that's the quantum explanation I'm
saying you know
electricity's that drill bit curling in
place that's a different mechanism and
so now we have a competing mechanism for
how handing one electron out of time
what it what it really means and you
know I think there is a way of showing
that even with an experiment what you
have to do is put all that under vacuum
high vacuum ultra-high vacuum hopefully
if you can do it on the moon that'd be
great you you know natural minus 11th
range
and you know when you have no particles
you have no no electricity that's the
issue you can't be shooting electrons
because electricity is not a flow of
electron balls even under quantum or
under you know normal electricity that
we have out there the explanation for
electricity is the electron goes from
atom to atom if you remove the atom the
electron beads don't go across and
that's what these people have in their
minds they think that electricity is
just a flow of a bunch of electrons and
that those electrons can move through
the vacuum without any atoms that's not
true that's what's wrong that's also
what's wrong with the electric universe
by the way they believe that you know
electrons are just shot little beads
that are shot from one galaxy to another
without any atoms in between and you
can't do that electricity is not the
flow of electron beads at least all by
themselves you need an atom and they
never learned this ok so what's the
issue the issue is that there is a
different explanation for what
electricity is one is the Cannonball
mechanism the other ones that when I
propose which is the drill bit totally
in place ok and that's a serpentine I'm
saying electricity is a bunch of atoms
that which are connected as a as a
serpentine as a long row of atoms all
interconnected and they're curling in
place that's my explanation for
electricity so I have a different
mechanism and again since we're talking
about invisible entities I think all
options are on the table all of them
should be considered side by side equal
footing there's no reason to reject one
or accept the other ok so here he peter
is going to illustrate his atom because
I asked him you know the key question
here is if if the Cannonball scenario
the fact that we're shooting electron
beads against the wall if that's true
let's concede that for a second we're
going to concede that we have a beam
shooter you know
the shooter you want and the shooting
beads or beans or whatever you want so
we have all these discrete particles
which are not really part of the bills
but we're gonna concede that as well
let's assume they're particles they're
corpuscles and they're hitting the wall
they're hitting the detector they're
hitting the screen whatever you've got
behind you the two slits the double
slits okay so we have that situation
then the question is before we can get
to that point what does your atom look
like and why is that important because
you know I need to see your Adam before
you can talk about the bead going out
there why is that important because if
if if the electron is a bead you're
telling me that you're proposing the
planetary model Niels Bohr's planetary
model the board Rutherford model that
they had from 1911 to 1919 when
Rutherford ran his proton experiment
that's the model they came up with they
said look it's an orbiting bead then
that was modified later on by you know
de Broglie he said you know it's a
ribbon that goes around and borne came
said no it's a shell or a cloud so they
came up with all these models but the
original model was the bead and they
still use the bead you know the the wave
integral wave model that de Broglie
proposed the shell model that poorn
proposed those are used at all they're
never used if you're talking about
ionization if you're going to talk about
electricity
they use the planetary model to this
thing and you say well is the atom you
know a ball and a bead going around it
they said well no that's the one we
teach in high school because it's the
easiest one it's the one people can get
their heads around but the atom is
really more complicated than that okay
once you draw the real model I mean if
it's a balloon like they're saying the
cloud model is just draw them cloud
model I think nobody's going to get
offended and what they say is well we
use this for this explanation
you know like if you got a do covalent
bonding or something well then we use
the cloud model because then they're
dealing with orbitals but when they talk
about you know electricity or ionization
they forget about the orbital and they
say well now we're gonna deal with the
beads because it's easier so they have
one bottle for this explains you another
model for that explanation that's the
problem and you don't know which which
is the true model the real Adam please
stand up that's the issue and so I asked
them you know please draw your atoms so
that I know that you're dealing with a
bead yeah and that's just the change on
a whim
yeah that's essentially what it what
they're doing here and and here you have
it this is his this is Peter here he's
holding a bowling ball you know he's got
a ball there and he puts it in his in
his little rag and that's on the left
hand side and so it's the bowling ball
on canvas analogy that they use for
space-time he's applying this now to the
atom he's gonna use this in quantum on
the right-hand side he draws it and the
circle door with the red line around it
that's gonna be the the thing I'm
concerned about what is that thing
that's holding the electron bead to the
nucleus and so he goes through these
different options he starts by saying
you know that well it's a rag yeah then
he says well I said what is this he says
it's a fabric and I'm saying what is the
fabric well it's a potential what do you
mean to put that potential is not a
fabric and potential so that concept you
can't say that a potentials a physical
object and as a potential of what he
says electromagnetic potential what the
hell is that well he says it's a voltage
so he uses all these words these
concepts he just replaces one concept
with another and just keeps ran ranting
about you know just with words and you
know and and it just completely you know
there's essentially no discussion we
never get to the bottom of it because he
never identifies the physical object and
he treats all of these as physical
objects again he violates the first
principle or the golden
principle which is that you need an
object to do physics he doesn't yet
understand that he does not understand
that you need a physical object and that
a potential is not a physical object and
therefore if the fabric is a potential
it's not a physical object if that's
what he means by fabric space-time is
not a physical object these are not
physical objects they're not doing
physics they're violating the golden
principle which says you need a physical
object to do physics this is where the
problem is and he doesn't realize that
he's dealing with concepts and he treats
them as objects that's what's happening
here so here I see a show a little
blow-up of his atom essentially there's
the bead
okay the electron beam he labels them he
talks about the nucleus there and that's
Peters atom and again I want to know
what the gray stuff is the great stuff
that prevents the electron from running
away yeah yeah then he wants to blame
semantics when you call him honest his
use of kazakh yeah I'm doing semantics
and and what is he doing right that's
the problem with mathematical physics
they do semantics and they accuse you of
bringing semantics objections but
they're the ones who are saying
space-time is a physical object what
other thing are you gonna raise against
that other than the fact that they're
using concepts as object that is a valid
criticism because that's what they're
doing in there saying well you know
you're using you're bringing semantic
argument yeah because you're treating a
concept is that you're saying that love
is the you know can break a window
that's what you're telling me and you
know you can't do that not in physics
you can do that in poetry you can do
that in ordinary speech you know that's
fine but you know in the case of fizzy's
love does not break windows does not
make holes in the wall you can't say
that you can't say that love holds the
electron to the nucleus you can't say
that love holds earth to the Sun you
can't say that that's what these people
are saying when they say potential
voltage gravity's space space time
that's what they're doing they're using
their bending low
what they're doing they're bending
concepts okay so what does he propose
well he proposes a corrugated something
you know he has his ball in his rag and
essentially this is what he's proposing
he's saying there's a ball and it is
pushing down some kind of medium and in
this case these wavy things and I'm
trying to figure out what this wavy
thing is that keeps the electron bead
there the red one from leaving the atom
that's what I want to know I just want
to know what the wavy stuff is but he
realizes that this is a two-dimensional
scenario essentially what he's saying is
the same thing as space-time he says the
ball weighs down this canvas this this
fabric or maybe the fabric is already
warped and bent and the electron just
sits in there and get stuck fine but he
realizes this is a 2d scenario so he
immediately corrects himself and says
I'll hold it but you know it's it's
actually a fluid more like a fluid
because the fluid is supposed to be
3-dimensional whereas this scenario is
two demential so he quickly changes that
because he knows he he's gonna be pinned
on that and so he goes into this and
here it is let's see here's the the
fluid scenario okay and now we have the
ball in uh you know in a fish tank now
we have a 3d scenario right because you
know the waters all over you know so the
ball is floating in this in this three
dimensional fluid right and he does
mention that it's really an ether theory
or ether proposed so ether hypothesis or
whatever he introduces the ether yeah
which I'm sure that all people in
quantum would reject it would not accept
this as valid but this is his proposal
he says yeah it's a fluid but if it's a
fluid you can see that the fishies
that are flying in there they're not
being attracted to anything because of
the fluid if you're in a fluid you're
not you still have not explained the
mechanism of what pulls that electron
bead to the center of the atom
what pulls it assuming there is a fluid
called a rag cada whatever you want to
call it I mean I don't care at this
point you caught a fabric what keeps the
electron bead tied to the nucleus you
can't say a fluid because the fluid
doesn't give me a mechanism you know
just and you can try this at home if you
don't believe me I mean you can just go
in there and say okay look I'm gonna put
a bowl of water and you throw the ball
plastic ball in there if you want maybe
a heavier ball so it kind of sinks a
little bit or put a fish just put a fish
in a bowl and see if it's attracted and
put uh I don't know a magnet or
something on the outside put a or if you
want to do it gravitationally put an
elephant on the outside and see if the
fish gets attracted to the elephant
because it's floating in a fluid you
need to have a mechanism a physical
mechanism that's what mathematical
physics doesn't have for space and for
quantum mechanics so whether you're
talking about general relativity or you
know the macro world or the micro world
they cannot explain attraction this is
the big problem at track you cannot
explain attraction with discreet beads I
always use the example here if I can do
it you know
two balls very simple experiment you can
do this at home always in the presence
of a train relativist tell me how this
ball pulls on this one if they're both
discreet and you can pull these in a
fluid you can put them in a rag if you
want yeah here's my right I got a right
to you know here I'll put one here on
the other one there okay so there you
have it okay let's see there is their
pool this is a 2d scenario so he's gonna
reject it he's gonna say well yeah
that's not really true okay so this
cannot be used because it's a
two-dimensional scenario so you would
have to put them in a fluid for it to be
a three-dimensional scenario in other
words around the nucleus everywhere
around
yes so if this is the nucleus and this
is the electron what in the fluid
what mechanist by what mechanism does
this fluid keep this one tight to that
one that's which he's got explained and
you can't explain that Earth around the
Sun you can't explain it with electron
bead around the nucleus you cannot use
this analogy not with a fluid and so
this is where these people fail and this
is where you get a pitch until they come
with an answer or you know throw in the
towel they have to admit that they
cannot explain this okay yeah a rag so
that so this is the issue the issue is
that you know whether we talk about the
space-time scenario or we talk about the
atomic scenario macro world micro world
it doesn't matter they cannot explain
what attaches one discrete entity to
another discrete entity they have to
explain what environment or what medium
these things are in and how that medium
produces that attraction fluid cannot do
it you cannot just put ether and say
what's ether and I'm gonna throw a bunch
of ether in there yeah you can put water
if you want you can put air if you want
all these are valid mediums to test your
theory right put air does you know a
ball get attracted because the air does
something to the ball no obviously not
so you cannot produce attraction with in
any medium in which you have a fluid a
gas or something you know similar to
that and this is what they're trying to
do and they're trying to get away with
that you got to pin them down so that
they find the admit no we cannot have a
mechanism we don't have a mechanism all
we have is a mathematical description
that we can accept but to say that they
have a physical mechanism you know
physics no they they they have to admit
that they don't and this is the problem
with essentially where we where we went
this discussion last time what I'm gonna
do next I'm going to go into the slit
experiment partly because I I just put a
video out on the slit and I'm finishing
writing the paper on that as well so
that's gonna be out probably the first a
few weeks of January I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be putting videos and papers on
what I covered in the conference in
Buenos Aires
and so those are gonna be online pretty
soon and I want you to read them I was
gonna publish them before going to
Buenos Aires but I thought no I'm gonna
present them I got a lot of feedback and
that's good because it allowed me to
modify the paper and that's essentially
what peer review is I have no problem
with peer review but I want peer review
to be constructive and not you know just
censorship you know where the guy says
oh his religion is different than mine
so I'm not gonna let him publish his
paper
no it's gotta be like you know let's
discuss you say oh oh how about this and
how about that and say oh that's
interesting you know I like your point
of view so now I'm going to modify my
paper based on the inputs that I got and
I'm gonna be putting that in the next
couple weeks anyways okay okay well doc
a show we call a person with same name
Stoke Gazoo okay so you're my namesake
not so much and they are so interesting
okay I'm glad did someone learn
something I learned something as well
when people give me feedback because you
know I do get even for people who hate
my guts and that's good because that way
I know where they're coming from
this is and this is important too you
need to have feedback and yeah I make
mistakes believe me and I changed a lot
of stuff in my life because of the
mistakes I made I made myself through
mistakes you can say so anyways you know
I'll be here on Wednesday I'm going to
be talking about the slit experiment and
I'm gonna be dealing with because he did
Harpal a lot on the slit experiment and
I'm gonna address that because now the
video is out in
I'm finishing writing the paper so it's
appropriate to do it this Wednesday so
we'll see you then
see you on Wednesday and good luck until
then have a Merry New Year's over here
it's called gonna go to the river we're
gonna see the last time I was there they
didn't throw firecrackers or or any of
those you know traditional what is it
forget the word the whatever the
firecrackers now they're using drones
and so I maybe see drones again this
year okay we'll see you on Wednesday and
have a happy new year
bye-bye